good morning
welcome to the planning committee third
of november 2021
i would like to
welcome you to this meeting i will now
ask the government's officer to read the
domestic arrangements and the fire
regulations thank you
welcome to this meeting of the baber
planning committee
sorry i'm all over the place this
morning please ensure that you maintain
social distancing from all other persons
whilst in the chamber and in the
communal areas please ensure that you
wear a face covering at all times unless
you're sitting down or if you're exempt
from doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and why it's provided please
ensure that microphones are turned off
when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking if you are attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
we will be using the e-voting for this
meeting on the model dub app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium ground floor area
and walkways if you are in the atrium at
the time of the alarm follow the signs
to the nearest fire exit use the stairs
not the lifts do not re-enter the
building until it's told safe
to do so
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to consent it to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
thank you chair thank you claire
introductions today area planning
manager is mark russell
the legal advisors ian to pray
case officer sam
samantha summers and government officers
claire philpott
we have no board members attending
claire okay right
then we'll move on apologies for absence
and substitutions
not received chair okay
any declarations of interest
nope
moving on
have you all had a copy of the minutes
of the last meeting
are there any factual corrections
if not can i have a proposal thank you
adrian
thank you sue councillors
and to raspberry
i will now ask you to
set up the electronic votes
thank you chair members if you go to
your app and select the plus sign in the
top right hand corner
this item is now in progress
that's the beer can i take your boat
please thank you
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous thank you very much
the minutes are confirmed that will be
signed at the end of this meeting
notifications and petitions
none received
site inspections
we have a request for a site visit and
this will be presented by sam samantha
if you would be so kind
councillor ayers has requested a site
visit for the sudbury medical center
which is uh going to be uh located on
the current lorry park between waitrose
and the kingfisher center
just
just getting the presentation up now
okay
um just a couple of plans and also some
photographs to show you the area to give
you an indication of whether you feel
that a site visit is necessary or not
um the site is the hatched area which
sits between waitrose on
the west side and the kingfisher
leisure center just to the north east
there
the site takes in part of the public car
park and the lorry park
that is the red line site plan
the purple lines are public footpaths
that crisscross the area
this is a current
uh
block plan just showing where the lorry
park is and the public car parking area
and this is the proposed site layout
it's a
part two story part three-story uh
building
tucked into
beside the waitrose store
there'll be
some parking
parking uh
mouse isn't working
[Laughter]
okay so there'll be staff car parking in
this area here
and then parking for patients
in this area
just some photographs of the site this
is the entrance to that area waitrose is
on the right hand side kingfisher
and the public car park is on the
left-hand side
this is the waitrose store
the building uh is not going to be any
taller than the turret on the top of the
waitrose store
tucked behind this tree belt here
is where the um
the lorry park actually is and you can
probably just make out some of the
waitrose delivery vans uh just in that
area there that are parked on the uh
lorry park
this is the kingfisher looking from the
site towards the kingfisher
these this row of trees here will be
removed to enable the development
this is the lorry park itself
again this is the lorry park from the
back of the site looking out towards the
public car park area
thank you
thank you any questions councilors
thank you mr chairman
um
there has been quite a lot of
controversy about the footpaths and as
good as those photographs are and i i
realize how good they are there is a
concern about the parking around that
footpath which takes us onto the valley
walk so to my way of thinking
uh for me personally of course it's not
too far but i would like the site visit
uh has agreed with
suez who has put it forward for a site
visit
thank you
any other
answered
german um
where are the lorries going to go if we
do if we if we shift them from there and
who owns the site
do you know who's making the application
site
um
the the council currently own the site
is going to be sold to the nhs for um
making uh
the medical center possible
part of the site um
which concerns the footpaths isn't
actually within that ownership it will
stay within the council's ownership and
that allows for deliveries to
the waitrose store and turning areas for
the tracks
[Music]
in terms of the other footpaths there is
a fence that runs around the site
that is to be maintained by the council
for the future
so maintenance and ongoing works to for
uh pedestrian safety will be the
responsibility of the council not the
landowners in the future
i i think cancer hinting that
the answer to your question can't be
reached today i think it's something
you'll have to ask when the
application's been made before committee
that's a beer
just to follow on that and i think
you've answered it the the weight rose
lorries i assume that that they would
park on their property rather than on
council property
um
yes they they will be parking in the
area that they currently park on i
believe that is actually council owned
because they park on land
that belongs to the council within the
lorry park complex at the moment
i'm assuming that that will continue in
the future
okay so we have a proposal and a second
uh any more questions council buzzfeed
can i just ask sue why she thinks that
we ought to go and visit it
um well i've because um unfortunately
sudbury is so close to essex border and
i feel everyone should be aware of
you know everything about it the
facilities and what it would do and i
just it's up to people to choose if they
want to come there or not
but i just i just feel it would be
it would help everyone's decisions just
to see the surrounding area because as
council osborne said there have been
some
objections so if we have a clearer
picture as possible i just think it's
useful thank you
any other questions
thanks to osborne
uh thank you mr chairman yeah yeah i i
i totally agree with
with the situation with the
uh i know there's been consultation with
with the hardwick house
however
gainesville trail actually runs onto the
valley walk and that footpath is a
connecting
position to that to that gainsborough
trial so um
you know i'd like
i personally would like to to have the
opinions of the uh committee on that in
that situation thank you okay
that's the beer
i can't see where it affects
the essex side there we've got the river
down there and what have you um
the footpath i can understand what
councillor osborne is saying um but i
don't think it affects the essex side
in fact it affects great corner more
than anybody else i would have thought
perhaps we'll find out in the side visit
cancer beer
thank you mr chairman i can understand
some people wanting to us to to have a
look at where the footpath goes etcetera
but what are the actual planning reasons
for us having a site visit because i
can't see any at the moment
i think one of the reasons is that it's
considered controversial so
and as we know
a lot of you a lot of you're looking but
to some of the people
in europe and i think
what's the reaction of the planning
department
which it's up to members obviously um i
mean we can't get into the merits of the
case today because the arguments are
here it can be fair etc but if
if there are elements of the layout and
its relationship that surroundings that
members aren't getting from the
submitted documents then there's your
reason to have a look
counseling thank you mr chairman um well
certainly it's controversial
um but i would have thought we could see
quite a lot from the photographs and
plans that are coming forward um i'm not
sure um there's a necessity
there's no other planning reasons i
don't think but it's certainly
controversial
thank you um i'm just wondering does
everyone know the site
i mean because it's like everything if
you don't know the site it's good to
have a look at the site and it's good to
be explaining the site
and and
like dave um mr council busby said
before it's good to have these site
visits
any more comments you have you have a
proposal in front of you
if you have no more comments we'll
we'll just take a vote
and
you've just said to that
we had councillors
in council
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you members chair that's eight
votes four two against and one
abstention
so that's carried
carrie and it will be
next wednesday morning we're looking to
bring this item to the first of december
the chair so
you usually make this the end of
november for the site visit but it could
be earlier if you want
any shorts about early or late
next week it's free isn't it next week
is free yes
yeah
okay can i just make a comment excuse me
can i just make a comment please mr
chairman yeah um the consultation that's
been taken place with that car parking
will like be available at the uh
the um
well now the the full count the
committee meeting thank you
sorry
i didn't quite understand it and
understand it
the consultation that has been taking
place has been out for in market in the
in market square
from hardwick house will that will that
information from them be available at
the meeting
excuse me if i might i think counselor
osborne is getting confused with the
consultation of the nhs consultation
rather than our consultation as a
planning matter
can we ask
would you like it at the committee
meeting or at the site busy
okay i will contact the agent and see
whether that information is available
might not
um would we normally have a consultation
report given to us at a site inspection
i could understand it coming to the the
council meet the plan even but i i don't
think it's necessary for us to have that
at the site inspection
the
controversy virtual of the footpath
uh stands out a long way and
as far as i can see the nhs is not
actually identified as
for certain items on that footpath
whether that
is uh
going to be okay they've not answered
really the question about the footpath
that is the reason for that
okay i thought the the whole point of
the site inspection is to is to furnish
us with in
information as to where this dwelling
building's going to be
and uh obviously the footpath is
important i'm not saying it isn't but
that shouldn't be um
i'm going to say we're having a site
visit we'll ask for the information with
the idea that if it is
there in time for the site visit it can
also be used at the planning application
stage as well um i see no no unless
there's any reason why i can't ask for
that
okay um so that's what i would propose
we do and i would set the date for next
wednesday for the site visit because we
might want
the wednesday afternoon they must
arrange that for um
okay everyone remain for the site visit
for next week
good morning
well normal normally you have them 9 30
and this is a good reason why not
check we asked the people who live
further away
what time they would like because a lot
of us live closer and i think we should
think of the people who live further
away
to answer this question thank you well
it's normally we have them at 9 30
unless is a request the reason not to
whether it's here or whether it's a long
way away that's been the practice
sorry
can you up
because this is going to affect the
residents of great cornard considerably
do we
can we invite the corner
district councillors
to attend this site inspection because i
think it's very important
um because that does affect
uh the great corner because one of the
the proposal is that they closed the
surgery in great corner
uh in favor of this new building in
sudbury yeah
but that's not really a matter for
planning matter that that's something i
think they need to know
but yeah i think that's probably that's
looking at the planning merits and then
obviously i presume b at the committee
to give their uh word then council beer
perhaps
everyone happy with coronard being
invited to send them parish councils
everybody
to sorry are we talking about the
district members representing cornard
well i think i'd only say we need to be
consistent with
other
looking at my government's colleagues uh
at this point i mean we
i suppose it would tie in with practice
of committing normally we ward members
are invited to speak and if they're not
if they're not a regular even if they're
not a regular member of committee but we
we might occasionally invite other ward
members if it's a case of a closeness to
a boundary or a neighboring issue but
it's a matter
of judgment really as to whether it's
right in the individual in the
circumstance
it's
it's very controversial in great corner
and i think we do need those cornered
members to be present at the site
inspection i think chairman it's a
matter of i think we've said in the past
and looking at my colleagues that it's
the chairman's discretion it's not
really something with the committee
votes on as to whether the chairman can
say
um that there is an um
this is in ex parish but it's so close
to why parish all the traffic goes
through white parish that we ought to
really invite them as well but i mean if
you you can hear the views of your
colleagues on the committee chairman but
i think that's your discretion okay
thank you for that
any more comments before i say we'll
meet 9 30 next wednesday morning
in car park new entrance there any lady
i'm good in it
yes
[Music]
it's it's councillors ward and this is
the senior single councillor award
but there are three wards in tudbury
and all three board members are invited
are
they the request was to invite the great
corner district
they're coming anyway one two three
there'll be a representative of each
ward there
can we just please move on i think it's
enough thank you chair sorry
dropping that caveat here um i
officially still need to do the code
risk assessment on this so we could just
slightly
tailor the wording to that effect i have
to do that but you know i appreciate
there's no problem
next week
nighter
thank you
moving on
scheduled planning applications now i
can tell you that the planning
application dc 2101
802 that was going to be second on the
list today has been withdrawn and will
be coming back to us again another day
so moving on we are now on to
planning application
dc 2004 663
east land east
land
east of the council country medical
center in east virgo sam please you're
going through the presentation
thank you chair
um this is an agenda item for a deed of
variation to the section 106 agreement
but land east of the constable country
medical center on heath road in east
bergot
the proposal for reserve matters came to
committee on the 16th of june of this
year for the erection of 75 dwellings a
preschool neighborhood hub comprising a
swimming pool office space and a local
shop
public open space and associated
infrastructure and landscaping
members resolve to grant reserve matters
for access layout scale appearance and
landscaping subject to some changes to
the section 106 agreement attached to
the outline planning commission
as a reminder to members of the site in
question this is an aerial photograph
showing the site marked with the red dot
which sits adjacent to the medical
center and opposite the high school
the changes to the section 106 included
the definition of a registered provider
the definition was changed to include
east bergot community land trust to
enable the village to secure some
affordable units for local people
the other changes were to the mix and
tenure of the affordable units and the
addition of iran's
contribution the mix of affordable units
was incorrect in the committee report
but in the table of papers was amended
this is the mix that members agreed to
on the 16th of june
however the tenure was not shown on that
table
the committee report referred to eight
one-bedroom flats and there are actually
six one-bedroom flats and two
two-bedroom flats this table
shows an extract of the deed of
variation with the correct tenure and
mix that has been agreed with strategic
housing
the recommendation of offices is that
members delegate authority to the chief
planning officer to agree to the section
106 deed of variation
on terms to his satisfaction as set out
in the committee report
and these are for the changes to the
tenure and mix the rams contribution and
the definition of the registered
provider
thank you
thank you sam
i should have asked cancer hinton
whether he's staying on the committee or
acting
i thought you might be thank you
any questions from members of the case
officer
councilman
just one quick one on the
the position of the east bergholt
community land trust
um
does that mean that all of the inverted
commas social housing will be under
their control or just the proportion of
it
and
presumably they can allocate those
purely for local occupants if they
wanted to
what it gives the community land trust
is an opportunity to bid for the
affordable units
so
they could be a mix of registered
providers they could just be one
or it gives them the opportunity to get
into to purchasing some of the
affordable units should they wish to if
the money is available
so we could end up with a real mishmash
of
providers on that side
we could do
yeah
any other questions
it's not moving on there's no
public representatives at all um so we
just moved straight into debate anybody
want to open the debate or
make a proposal
counselor barrett yeah i think it's
fairly straightforward this so um quite
happy to propose
the
officer's recommendation
to delegate to the chief planning
officer
okay we have a proposal number second
council osborne do you wish to speak or
are you just
happy too
any more comments before we go straight
to a vote
nope can i ask you to set a vote please
claire
chair
members that vote is now in progress
council of beer can i take your
thank you
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous
thank you very much
moving on
thank you
we're all set
dc 210
2296 land of the rear of the plow and
fleece in
great green cockfield
and invite sam again please
thank you shane
um there are some extra papers in your
table papers um unfortunately the parish
council of corkfield weren't able to
come today
so they have provided some
comments which are in your table papers
also there is a
revised consultation response from a
county floods team
which have removed their holding
objection they're now happy to approve
the scheme
uh this application seeks reserve
matters for layout scale appearance and
landscaping for 28 dwellings at land to
the rear of the plough and fleece in
great green corkfield
the application site is the hatched area
on the plan
the site sits
in the northwestern corner of great
green with
the actual green just located here
there is a tree belt along the northern
edge of the site
just here
duke's meadow
is to the east which is this housing
development here
the plow and peace public house is to
the south
and to the west of the site
at the entrance here
is a development currently under
construction for 10
dwellings
the site would be accessed from berry
road through the development of ten
dwellings into the field beyond
which is just
here
there's a footpath link proposed along
here which links the development to
great green
the site sits outside of the built-up
area boundary of great green which is
shown with the brown line
the principle of development on site was
established by the granting of outline
planning permission dc190475
there is a public footpath which is
shown
with the dotted green line
opposite the site
there are listed buildings close to the
site all are grade two listed
we have a old
old house farm just here to the east
and
forge
cottage
to the south here
the heritage team did raise concerns at
outline stage on the principle of
development on the site because of the
potential impacts to the setting of the
designated and non-designated heritage
assets
during assessment of the principal
outline stage it was considered that the
public benefits of 11 affordable homes
public open space a financial
contribution of 18 060 pounds towards
highway improvements
and biodiversity enhancements outweighed
the lesson substantial harm to their
heritage assets
at outline stage an indicative site
layout was agreed after the parish
council and planning officers negotiated
changes to the plan
with the developer
outline permission was granted for the
erection of 28 dwellings and also the
repositioning of three dwellings
of the
the development of 10 at the front of
the site
to allow
the site to be accessed through so
these dwellings here
have been repositioned it was a colder
sank before
with the development for 10. so this is
being pushed back to either side to open
up the site to allow access
two conditions were added to the outline
planning permission
to ensure that details shown on the
indicative layout plan which you can see
on your screen would be included in a
future reserve matters application
the first is condition 21 which states
that the mix of housing should be that
shown on the plan
which is the writing in that top right
hand corner
this included five bungalows
11 affordable dwellings
and
dwellings comprising
five two bed units thirteen three bed
units and ten four bed units
the second condition concerns the layout
of the site condition twenty two uh
required that the layout
of the reserve matters should reflect
that of this indicative plan
a particular note
is the retention of the
northern tree belt which is located here
a landscaping belt between the
development and duke's meadow along here
a footpath link to great green which is
here and a
central uh public open space
which is centered here
that was negotiated from a previous
scheme where it was tucked into the
corner of the site
out of the way which we felt was not
appropriate
also
on this indicative plan was shown five
bungalows along this sensitive boundary
with duke's meadow
and we felt that that was necessary to
ensure that
residential immunity of the properties
in duke's meadow were protected
this is the site layout plan that's
being considered by members today
the tree belt to the north is to be
retained
there's a landscaping belt shown between
duke's meadow and the development
five bungalows are proposed along this
section here
and a one and a half story uh row of
three dwellings just here
and the footpath link to great meadow
just here
the public uh open space is centrally
located
uh there are 11 affordable units on the
site five bungalows and a mix of two
three and four bedroom dwellings is set
out in the outlying permission
drainage on the site
will be held in a swale on the central
public open space
the parish council have raised an
objection to this and believe that they
have been misled during discussions with
the developer
because no mention of the swell was made
during those negotiations
annex ii
of the mppf contains a glossary of terms
used in the framework
open space is defined
as all open space of public value
including not just land but also areas
of water such as rivers canals lakes and
reservoirs which offer important
opportunities for sport and recreation
and can act as visual immunity
the swale will be a wet swale for most
of the year
which is planted with wild flowers
trees will be planted around the
perimeter
although the swell is too small to act
as a sporting facility it is considered
to give visual immunity to the future
residents of the development
with a large proportion of the dwellings
looking out onto this area
the swale gives the development a sense
of space and openness and will provide
an important water source for wildlife
the concerns of the parish council are
noted and can
can be read in the table papers
suffolk county council floods team have
no outstanding concerns in terms of
flooding or public safety on site
this plan shows the access through the
site from berry road
just here
passes through the development of ten
dwellings which are just outlined
just here
uh with the repositioning of three plots
two on this side and one on this side
the 28 dwellings have parking on plot
other than three affordable units which
are those one and a half story units
just here
in this
southeastern corner there is a
parking court for those properties
there are an additional eight visitor
parking bays around the public open
space
and they just marked here three here
three here
and two just here
all market dwellings have garages that
will have electric vehicle charging
points
the affordable units have small sheds
for secure bicycle storage
the parking on the site is compliant
with current parking standards
both corkfield and bradfield sinclair
parish councils have raised highways
concerns over the increase in
traffic using the village lanes and also
about larger vehicles during the
construction of the site
suffolk county council highways have
raised no objection to the scheme and
high on highway safety grounds
this slide shows the scale of the
the proposed dwellings
there are five bungalows
along
this boundary with duke's meadow
one and a half story dwellings just in
this corner here
and then the remaining houses that you
can see here are two story
the scale of the dwellings along the
sensitive boundary with duke's meadow is
considered to protect the residential
immunity of the existing residents
this plan shows the tenure of the
dwellings the blue dots
are the market dwellings
so
they are along this northern boundary
and around here
uh the blue dot oh sorry
nine affordable rental properties are
shown with the pink dots
uh which are these properties here
and there are two shared ownership
properties shown with the green dot just
here either side of that public footpath
going through to great green
the appearance of the dwellings will
blend with those of the development of
ten in design and also in materials a
limited materials palette is proposed
which gives the development a sense of
place a mix of red brick render and
weatherboarding is proposed with either
a red or grey plain tile to the roof
these materials are considered to blend
with the existing dwellings in duke's
meadow and also the development of ten
to the west of the site
this shows the proposed street scene the
tops
stop the top
scene shows that's too many isis sorry
getting in a medal the two-story market
dwellings along the northern boundary
with the uh backdrop of the tree belt
behind
so
just here
the next [ __ ]
the next scene shows the bungalows
and the one and a half story dwellings
also with that landscaping belt behind
which forms a boundary with duke's
meadow
um
and
this bottom one
shows the affordable
units pairs of semis and also the shared
ownership houses and one of the market
dwellings
just to that southern boundary
moving on to the house types
these are the link detached
three-bedroom bungalows with single
garages
this is the detached bungalow in brick
this is also three bedroom property with
single garage
this is the same
house type
but is finished with render
all five bungalows have three bedrooms
and a market properties
this is the terrace of three affordable
rental dwellings they're finished in the
same red brick as the market dwellings
and have two bedrooms each these
properties are one and a half stories
high and a set in the south eastern
corner of the site with the parking uh
court just tucked in the corner of the
site
this is the detached shared ownership
affordable dwelling
finished in rinda and has two bedrooms
there are two of this house type with
the footpath to great green
running between the two properties
this is a three-bed affordable pair of
semi-detached dwellings
these are finished in red brick there
are total of three pairs of this house
type
two pairs finished in brick and one in
render
and this is the same affordable but
showing you the render type
moving on to the market dwellings this
is a four bedroom in brick
the same house type
but in weatherboard
and again the same house type in render
this is also four bedrooms with a mix of
render and weatherboarding
the same house type but using
weatherboarding and brick
and this is a four bedrooms house in
brick
this is the final four bedroom house
type finished in brick
there's just one type of three bedroom
dwelling
and
there are a total of seven three-bedroom
dwellings on the site
ten are bought at sorry ten four-bedroom
market dwellings all dwellings will have
air source heat pumps including
the affordable dwellings
moving on to the landscaping
this plan shows the tree planting around
the swale
and the circle
circles are the trees that are proposed
on the site
there's also quite a bit of tree
planting along the roadside particularly
on that northern boundary
there's also a group
planted here in this car parking court
this shows the tree belt to be retained
along that northern boundary
and the proposed landscaping belt
between the bungalows
and uh duke's meadow just here
there is a proposed grouping of trees in
the car parking court the affordable
dwellings
the trees shown along the southern
boundary just here
are to be retained
this again shows the trees
um
on the on the street and around the
swale
so around here and also the trees along
this road
the scheme includes biodiversity
enhancements to the site which include
integrated bat boxes
standalone bat boxes bird boxes swift
nest bricks and hedgehog fencing
these are all important features of this
edge of settlement development and the
existing woodland will be utilized for
the bird boxes and standalone back boxes
the plan also shows the five metre
landscaping buffer with duke's meadow
the trees planted will be outside of any
boundary fences
i don't have too many photographs of the
site
this is probably the most
useful in terms of understanding the
site in the surroundings
this is the access point
just here
going through that development of 10 at
the front of the site and then entering
the site which is currently an unused
field
these are the dwellings in duke's meadow
that share a boundary with the site
the five meter landscaping buffer would
sit behind these dwellings
and then beyond that the five bungalows
this is taken from within the site
looking towards that shared boundary
with duke's meadow
the bungalows and the landscape buffer
would be along that boundary with those
houses
this is the existing tree bout along the
northern boundary and the two-story
dwellings would be located here
this is a cgi
given by the architect showing how the
site is likely to look in the future
the scheme is considered to reflect that
shown at outline stage and therefore the
application is acceptable
at the time of writing the report there
was an outstanding matter of suds and a
holding objection details have been
received to address the remaining lack
of information
suffolk county suffolk county council
floods team have lifted their objection
and therefore the recommendation is
slightly different to that in your
agenda the recommendation is for
approval of the reserve matters with
conditions set out on page 55 of the
agenda
thank you
thank you samantha
any
questions counselor you are first
thank you mr chairman um
just a quick question did you say that
there were air source heat pumps for all
properties
that's correct yes right and the
other part of my question would be the
parking court next door to the block of
three affordable houses
as there are there is only provision for
electric charging points for
secure garages
what happened in that area and how is it
controlled to make sure that
every tom dick and harry can't go and
charge his car up there
okay so none of the affordable houses
have uh the car charging points it's
just the market properties who have
garages that have that facility
um we
gave every
house on the scheme and at least one car
charging point
okay
apologies for that
where where would that charging point be
for that terrace perhaps that's a
question that we could ask the agent um
during during his um chat
counselor you remember
yeah thank you mr chairman
is the old uh
it's the old chestnut i'm afraid to do
with the swale
um
samantha has spoken about the depth of
water in that swell what health
safety matters
around that swell has been considered
please
at this moment there is no fencing
proposed around that i have discussed
that with the agent
they are quite happy for a condition to
be added
for details of fencing to be agreed um
if the scheme is actually approved today
thank you thank you and thank you mr
chairman i've got two questions slide
nine please um is that the
um
park and
uh block
uh
sorry slide nine
is that the parking block on the right
hand side down the bottom there and how
many cars can that hold
and is that where you're going to have
some of these charging points
that's my first question
i can't actually see the detail of
what's actually on the plan from here
i'm afraid
i know that all of the parking spaces
are
compliant with suffolk county council
highway standard
the agent might be able to
help me with how many parking spaces
excuse excuse me
can you can you wait till we ask you
please rather than butting in um
you also have time to speak and so i was
going to ask cancer beer to save his
question for when the agent speaks
that's fine
my second question then um
because he'll be able to give us the
amount that during that um
slowly 28 i think it is um oh well that
one that all right let it get to 28.
my question is that it's the area around
the
open area is there footpaths around that
or is this a tarmac footpath or is this
just a grass verge all the way around at
which people can drive up with their
cars and churn it all up
um i believe that it is grass verge with
uh the visitor parking
is there a slide then mr chairman that
shows that a bit clearer because
that one might do it but the last thing
we want is for that green area to be
used to park cars we all know what
happens on our states
and uh if they can get a car parked up
there the grass will be churned up we
need to protect that now whether that's
something we need to put to the
applicant in due course i don't know
certainly
we haven't got anything to protect that
have we
um i don't think there is anything to
protect at the moment there are trees
around most of that boundary so i think
that would probably stop some of the
parking
but
i know what you're going to say you
would like some bollards
well
we need either hedging mr chairman or
something physically to stop motorists
from a park and encroaching on that area
okay so that is something that we would
be able to secure by condition the
detail of that to be agreed at a later
stage
we can also ask the agent yeah well i
will put that question to them because
as you know mr chairman and many members
in this chamber we have these estates
and with the best will in the world
they end up with three or four cars
because the family grows up and they
learn to drive and what have you they've
got nowhere to park and if we don't make
this stand now it will get churned up
that will look awful okay thank you
thank
thank you chair
sam the shared ownership
houses
have got
the main public footpath
haven't they going through between them
what protection is envisaged for the
the people who are living in those
houses
because you can imagine it's going to be
quite it's i think it's the main
footpath isn't it
what protection is it gonna be because
there's gonna be a lot of traffic i
would have thought human traffic not
not cars and things but there will be a
lot of people using that bike some prams
and
people
yeah i believe that all of the gardens
are fully fenced
with hedgehog fencing
so it will be up to the river
be up to the rear of the house if you
like yes along the side and right to the
end yeah oh thank you thank you chad
thank you
parker
yeah thank you chad um
uh just maybe a small point i've
actually got two questions chair but
maybe the first one might be a small
point but um i picked up that you
mentioned the parish council felt
um
that they had been misled over the swale
um with with the developer um so can you
expand on that and then secondly and i'm
um you know rule me out if this is out
of order mr chairman but the applicant
according to the papers is sudbury group
limited but i can't find them at all on
the uh on the company's house website so
um
i always like to have a look and just
see who the applicants are so just
wonder if you can give any information
on those two items please
in terms of the applicant i can't really
give you
any details on that as such um the agent
might be able to verify that point
later
in terms of
the parish council during the outline
permission the application ran on for
quite a long time with lots of
negotiation
going on with the developer directly
that i wasn't included in
but also i had my own negotiations with
the developer so
the scheme that came forward
outline is what was agreed with um
the parish council and with ourselves
here
i think the confusion comes
we all know that
there has to be drainage on the site
when you're putting that many houses in
if it's over 10 it
it needs some suds
we all know that that normally goes to
the public open space either in crates
or swale
i don't think
i don't think the parish council
realized that that is normally the case
um so i think that's where they feel
that they were misled they saw it as
just a green grassed area
crates in this particular place it was
not acceptable to jason he wanted open
suds so
there is nowhere else on the site to put
it
thank you
my question council james
thank you
looking at the picture there those
market houses i think is that north west
the back gardens facing on the ones at
the top
and trying to have big those gardens
because looking at that picture it
doesn't there's going to be a lot of um
light in the back gardens there could be
a lot of shading
how long the gardens are
okay so
they are north facing gardens so they
will be limited with sunshine uh anyway
um and
you're quite right the trees will form
that backdrop
um but as the sun moves round from east
to
west
they will get some sunshine
all of the gardens are
good-sized gardens in modern terms
we use a a standard of 100 square meters
is really acceptable for
for family houses
they all
they all reach that standard
um
ideally they probably wouldn't be north
facing but on a site such as this
they will get light but only at certain
times of the day
any more questions
counselor buzzby
you say it so sweetly
they're supposed to be tenure blind the
affordable housing
but they don't have any garages so
won't make it obvious which ones are
which
it's a difficult one isn't it because of
the cost involved we hardly ever see
affordable dwellings with garages
in terms of their design and the
material pallets that used it is the
same for all of them they are smaller
dwellings they will look slightly
different of course they will
that is something for members to decide
whether that is acceptable or not
and how big are the garages where there
are garages will they take an suv
it's a good question
i assume that uh please i assume that
suffolk county council have looked at
the size of those garages they are all
um
they're parking standard compliant so i
would imagine that
whether
whether suffolk county council highways
have taken into consideration suv
particularly i don't know but there's
space on their driveways to park the
bigger vehicles if they will not fit in
the garage
but they've kept we've counted the
garage space as one of the parking
spaces so if it's not big enough to take
a car then it's not a parking space
highways have said it is big enough to
take a car
okay
thank you any more questions
no if not thank you sam hang on there
um we have
no
member of the parish council we have
no objector or a supporter we have mr
blaine mcmahon for the agent
and please thank you for trying to help
us out but but if you can wait to be
asked you've got three minutes to
address this and then you'll have plenty
of time to ask the questions answer the
questions that the members have got
thank you
good morning my name is blaine mcmahon
and i am the agent for this application
this application seeks to discharge
matters relating to the layout scale
appearance and landscaping following the
approval of the outline application in
february this year
the proposed development provides 28
dwellings of varying sizes in a pleasant
village location on the western edge of
the existing dukes meadow development
and has been designed to meet the modern
day living requirements of local people
and families
furthermore the development provides a
policy compliant level of affordable
housing and parking as
confirmed in the responses from
strategic housing and suffolk highways
and subsequently noted in the officer's
report
the dwellings have been designed in a
traditional style taking cues from the
local area to integrate with the
surrounding village character and in
particular the ten dwellings which are
currently under construction directly to
the west of this site
this has been achieved through a
carefully selected pallet of materials
and design details which creates a sense
of place for future residents
the dwellings will be built to current
building regulation standards with a
particular focus on sustainable design
principles this includes a commitment to
a fabric first approach through the
proposal of high performance thermal
insulation and energy efficient glazing
and window frames rain water harvesting
electric car charging points and air
source heat pumps are also provided to
all dwellings
following the outline consent a number
of recommendations were received from
lavender and ward member councillor
margaret mabry which have been
integrated into the developed design
proposals some of the key design
features include bungalows which are
proposed along the shared boundary with
the duke's meadow development with
bungalows having been identified as a
requirement for future years in the bay
but weber district council area
the green border between duke's meadow
and the development has been widened and
will be planted with more suitable
mature trees improving the privacy of
all few existing and future residents
the development is landscape-led and
responds to existing landforms to create
quality green infrastructure and
existing mature trees are retained to
soften the impact of the development
while acting as an ecological corridor
along boundaries
the site will be served by a single
access point from berry road and a
pedestrian cycle link will be provided
to as a direct route to the village
green
building front juice will provide a high
level of surveillance and security to
principal access routes and central open
space
finally i'd like to address the concern
raised by the parish council regarding
the central open space
the central open space and detention
basin have formed an important part of
the site's drainage strategy since the
flood risk assessment submitted with the
outline application identified that the
site's poor infiltration rates required
the use of attenuation storage in the
form of a basin
despite there being periods during
extreme rainfall events when the basin
will contain water this feature will in
combination with the proposed landscape
strategy provide a pleasant and
attractive outlook for all dwellings
which have been orientated to enable
views across it this design approach is
again confirmed as acceptable by the
planning officer in their report i'd
like to thank members and the chair for
giving me the opportunity to speak speak
in front of you all today and for the
officer for their recommendation of
approval thank you
thank you very much if you like to sit
tight i think you may have some
questions cancel a beer would you like
to kick off
um thank you mr chairman yes
um good morning you heard my question a
bit early but i'll rephrase it because i
quite liked your words of modern day
living and as we all know that people
have
more than two cars and we run out of
spaces
what precautions are you taking for that
green area which you saw on slide 28 to
stop
people abusing it because we all know
that if you if you run out of spaces
you're going to park as near as pop
possible to your property and a low
hedge
all the way around between the trees
would solve the problem i don't know
what precautions you'll perhaps take
from there that's one
um so actually if you look at the site
plan site layout plan itself we have
indicated bollards all around the edge
of the
open space so that will stop people
actually being able to drive up onto the
over the verge and spark on the green
um again
if
we do deal with the safety issue via
condition and and perhaps
install a estate rail um then again that
will prevent any parking and and will
remove the need for the bollards
um well in answer to that
um could you
put in a small um sort of like scaffold
pole
and put planting it in pension so that
would stop that rather than say ugly
bollards but i'm not what
that's just a point mr chairman my
second question is that um
the park and court
which
we've seen up there is
that park and for
properties abc or is that open to
anybody to park there because i can see
that little cul-de-sac of a parking
court
being used for repairs and all sorts of
things
uh no that will be conveyed specifically
to the three one and a half story
dwellings right so so that would be
controlled as far as you can do thank
you but i am quite concerned mr chairman
and to you that
you do pick up this problem which will
become a problem of people parking on
that green area and so i think
bullards don't always look attractive
but certainly if you put some
plant in there
that would stop it thank you
thank you
sorry hopefully the local member may
comment on that as well
um any more questions to the agent
councillor osborne
sorry cancel him
i know i can be schizophrenic but this
is ridiculous
um
just uh one point that's not it's not
been mentioned anywhere in our reports
or anything and it refers it links in
really to what cancer beer has been
saying about low hedges as well
who's going to look after the swale
stroke suds stroke grass areas open
space within this within this
a
site
management company has been
appointed to deal with all open space
and the maintenance of that
as part of one of
jason's
requirements for discharging his
condition
uh was to
provide suds maintenance plans which
include obviously includes the open
space as it doubles up as an attenuation
basin
thank you
thank you thank you very much i'm
actually very impressed with all of this
my real concern is the the open space
where that water will be
and what um
worried about as a retired teacher about
children and accessing that will there
be fencing whatever so that's one
question but the other one is slightly
facetious very the bio does bio
diversity in hearts enhancement strategy
strategy
you've missed out maybe putting koi carp
in the water so you can feed the herons
thank you
so in regards to the first point as i
said we would be happy to
as a condition provide evidence after
this
if this was to be approved as to how we
would
make sure people were safe in the use
and
milling around the site
uh in response to the second question um
again we can look at or someone could
come along and
put them in themselves
um
but yeah no but if that is something you
want then
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you mr chairman yes i did have a a
couple of quick quickies as mr
councillor would have said um
relating to councillor hinton's question
so i take it that the
management company will be charging
residents for the
uh per year for that uh work to be
carried out is that correct
yes
and the other question was and i'm not
sure if i've got the right situation or
5.3
you uh look at the concerns being raised
the application process has saw being
moved around the site
could you just give us an update on the
on the position of this because it's it
seems to be quite concerning it did on
the
uh it's noted that comments received
through publicity referred us
um
as far as i'm aware that's just soil
being moved from the to the 10 units at
the front of the site
so
obviously as part of this application
the levels have been agreed
um and if there is excess soil that's
been
moved around to the second half of the
site for whatever reason that will be
taken away again or will be made good by
the
tent the
contractor constructing the first 10
units
and i take it that
any of the
vehicles that are used for this will be
cleaned down before they make the
highways yeah a construction
uh management plan indicates all the
sort of cleaning requirements and
yeah various things like that so thank
you make sure that it's dealt with thank
you thank
you councillor parker
i'm thank you mr chairman i mean i'll
just come back if i can uh mr maman and
you know strike it out if it's not in
order mr chairman but um can't find the
subreddit group limited and can't find
the applicant
so yeah i just checked that myself um
and it's
incorrectly stated as sudbury group
sudbury homes limited
yeah sorry about that
thank you council jameson
thank you
hi um the report says you're going to
maximize the use of passive solar energy
in the layout and orientation of the
buildings and windows i wondered if you
could
expand on that a bit because the
buildings are all in different
directions i wonder how that's going to
work
so the passive solid design
yeah so in terms of how
it'll be
in combination with the insulation we're
using to make sure that there's a good
degree of air tightness within the
buildings and the windows themselves
will be energy efficient and then the
idea is that if you have a tight
building envelope
you're minimizing the amount of heat
that escapes during the winter months
which will reduce your energy bills and
any sun that is on your on your property
in some in winter months will actually
allow for some a degree of heating
um
[Music]
but yeah so it's all sort of like
an integrated approach to sustainable
design really which is in combination
with several items so when it says layer
and orientation of the buildings
because the buildings are all at
different orientations aren't they yeah
but obviously
primarily the dwellings are orientated
with with a elevation facing south east
or west so they'll always have the
benefit of some kind of sunlight or so
solar gain in those instances okay and
you decided not to use any pv panels on
these wonder why that was
uh so
[Music]
i did speak to the
contractor on this one and asked them
why they
felt that they didn't want to use solar
panels but they said that the energy
efficiency
requirements put on them by building
regulations could be met with met with
the installation of air source heat
pumps um and that pv sort of wasn't
needed
as well as those so it's just the case
of just going as far as building rigs
is that right
they
we are going to try and we are going to
aim or we are
aiming to make sure that the building
exceeds the current building regulation
standards
and that will be achieved through other
measures including as i mentioned the
windows the installation on site et
cetera
any more questions for you
council
thank you
uh you referred to the pedestrian cycle
path which would lead to the village
green yep
um have you thought about
funding a crossing
to get the
cycle stroke pedestrians across the road
no but i guess that could be something
that's dealt with by a section 106
agreement
i assume
that was if that was wanted
some kind of condition to continue with
my question in the same vein what do we
know what the speed limit is along where
the footpath comes out
it's 30 isn't it
30 yeah as soon as you enter the village
i think it turns into 30 zones
so is that is that where he starts the
village or
well the actual um motor vehicle
entrance to the to the site is that
still within 30. or is that beyond the
30. so what the the very lane access
that so
i'm not sure where the 30 comes in i
think it will probably just be just
before there
okay but i'm just thinking that it's it
could be a dangerous crossing because
it's on a curve
and you're encouraging children to come
out at that point and to go across that
road
i think they might need some assistance
i think a crossing would uh help them
but also generally slow traffic down
something we can look into
sam yes
um
there is already a section 106 in place
with the outline commission with over
ten thousand pounds towards uh highway
improvements for footpaths
there are no other crossings to great
green
from any of the other development sites
around the green
and i don't think it would be
appropriate to ask for one at this stage
that probably should have been picked up
at outline stage rather than this
reserve matters because we're just
looking at the detail of the plans at
this stage
so what are the tenths is the ten
thousand pounds being allocated to
um
i can't remember off the top of my head
um but it is for highway improvements to
footpaths
so i don't know whether that's in other
parts of
great green or whether it's specific
specifically along uh between the access
point and the pedestrian way
but that is in place already so we can't
ask for any more at this stage
presumably
the village could use
seal could it it sell contributions to
fund something like that if they need
help necessary
but certainly they could approach the
cell team and see whether that's
something that
that they could ask for
i'm not too sure of the details of
exactly what parish councils can ask for
with civil monies but possibly that
could be the case
that's a beer
well just following on from that there
was no request from the parish council
for a pedestrian crossing to be put
there and highways have obviously
been looked at and decided that it's
safe
and don't require it
but i think it could be useful in future
that we knew what the ten thousand
pounds
that
was being allocated where they were
going to spend that uh whether it was
that end halfway along or the other end
of the village so that might be
something in future that we should try
and get from them um
i don't know if it can be as easy as
that forthcoming it may be for something
that develops but i think it's important
that we do know that but i think i think
council beer that's something we will
have to put to the the
cabinet member for planning at some time
not not when he's here not while he's
here being rewarded accept that i had to
accept that thank you councillor park
thank you
are we still able to ask questions of
the um
um not not material at all to the
planning application per se but could i
just ask out of interest um
do your clients plan to use um
vapour's building control or outsource
can i just ask as a matter of interest
they'll use the local authorities
building control belief
no right well thank you very much but if
you'd like to remain there just in case
just in case they have another question
that you can answer
thank you very much indeed we now have
the ward member kansas um you have five
minutes to address the committee
thank you germany i'm i'm addressing you
as the ward member this morning
um i wondered if we could sam have the
um the plan of the outline
up is that possible i don't know if you
can split the screen or something
um
so yes thank you chairman um i have to
say that the parish council and the
community feel that they and you
have been sold a pup
because this is developing into
something different
particularly the good sized open space
which has become a smaller
area and is basically a hole in the
ground
you have heard from the planning officer
about your previous decision
which i'm sure you remember
and the balance you had to consider then
regarding the public benefit
particularly of the central open space
this had been negotiated during the
developers engagement with the paris
council and also
negotiations with the planning officer
the path from great green was to lead
into that open space
the open central sorry the central open
space was to afford good visibility
for the houses
to be able to see children who may be
playing in that area so if if i can just
refer to the plan chairman
you can see that the the link actually
went into
um the area of open space at the western
end
and you could um sort of
get an idea of of the size of that
because when you look at the current
proposal you'll see how it shrunk and it
now goes into well it ends up on a
roadway
so that link was was quite a an
important part of the considerations
because it came from great green
and led straight into the western area
of what we thought was going to be
public open space
it was also part of the changes to
de-urbanize the scheme
following heritage concerns
and those concerns you considered
against the public benefits
there's a little bit about that on page
41 and the top of page 42
and one of the principal public benefits
you identified was the provision of that
link and the public open space and
that's mentioned at paragraph 8.4
another point which is to do with the
shrinking of the central area
you will see that the gardens are now
larger
which is welcome
but
that that of course is at the expense of
the public open space which has shrunk
considerably
furthermore the opportunity has not been
taken to increase the depth of the rear
gardens at the eastern boundary
it even seems and this is only my
measurements but it seems that the
distance from those properties um to the
boundary is now
4.5 meters where it was five
so the opportunity to increase to move
the dwellings sort of into the centre if
you like
which has been taken on the the northern
and southern boundaries doesn't appear
to have been taken on the east and it
was at the east where there were the the
main concerns from duke's meadow which
is the development um to the east
lastly and thank you for picking it up
yourselves there's the issue of safety
the parish council are very concerned
regarding the safety of children playing
in this central area and its pond
we've heard that fencing can be provided
and i think would be required
probably further detracts from the
visual immunity of the area
i'm guessing that life belts may also
have to be
provided
to address safety issues
but the point is that the public benefit
is not what it was when you considered
the outline application
i believe that that public benefit in in
your balancing considerations was
absolutely key
lastly
this is an extra lastly because of
something that councillor busby
mentioned
i would support a funded crossing as
with the parish council i'm sure
great green is a fantastic facility it's
got a new adventure playground which
we've contributed to via sell
contributions
and anything that we could do to to help
people to to cross from outside of great
green if you like onto the green
would be welcome at the other side of
the green the parish council are already
considering whether they might be able
to fund a crossing
the planning officer is absolutely right
that there are currently no crossings
onto great green but it's a fantastic
facility um it's surrounded now by more
and more houses
and a crossing for that road albeit that
it's a 30
people do knit down there
and a crossing
on this side of the green or the other
side of the green or and the other side
of the green would be welcome
thank you chairman
thank you councillor arty
have we any questions for the ward
member
uh can you put the slide up where you've
got the duke's meadow and the proposed
it's that you talked about the
shrinking of the back gardens on the
eastern side
the development next door dukes meadow
believe it is i don't think there's any
green area there they've all got fairly
large gardens so there's no public
benefit from those houses being
from being built
um it does seem kind of harsh to
land this development with
a
requirement which wasn't applicable to
the one next door
i mean i agree i think it's better
if you've got the space but i understand
that there's drainage issues in
in this particular area and if it's just
a green
play space would that
deal with the drainage issues or you
have you got to have a sud space in
there
i'm not quite sure how that's a question
for me but
um the the point i was trying to make is
that the developer has taken the
opportunity to move
the
properties on the northern side of the
development a little bit south to
increase their their regards taking the
opportunity to move the ones on the
south a little bit north the effect of
that has been to squeeze the central
area which is now not public open space
anyway or not in the sense that it's a
recreation area for use by residents
all i was saying was that the
opportunity hasn't been taken
to move the the properties on the
eastern boundary slightly to the west
and increase their rear gardens which is
a shame because that was the principal
area of concern from the neighbouring
development at duke's meadow
they were this they were seeking to get
the greatest separation possible
but i accept that in terms of distance
to
um and i'm sure sam summers will confirm
this in terms of distance from the
proposed dwellings to the existing
dwellings in duke's meadow
it is more than the minimum requirement
isn't it but all i was saying was that
you know whilst the central area was
being squeezed it's a shame that the
opportunity wasn't taken um to actually
move those properties on the eastern
boundary a little bit to the west and
increase that separation further
thank you
council back did you have a question
i'm not sure that councillor arthur can
answer it but uh it's interesting is it
that you've got a sudden scheme
in
the new development
has duke's meadow had got any history of
flooding
not that i know of
apart from when there was a willow tree
that blocked the drain because it's
quite an open sight isn't it
it's quite an open area
yeah
so
it seems that the modern day requirement
to have a suds scheme
in the 70s development doesn't require
sunscreen it doesn't flood
okay
any more questions
no and thank you much council
thank you indeed right
we'll now open up the item for debate
with anybody like to kick off
i'll just move the officer's
recommendations with the additional one
that um you mentioned uh in your
presentation thank you
for approval do i have a second of that
here when we move on cancer barrett you
want to come in
thank you
thank you parker you wish to say
something yeah well i i will just
mention uh chairman um i i always take
the time to have a look and see you know
who applicants are in any given
application and i've i would you know
hence the question i asked about who
might be undertaking the building
control and i understand that you know
there's very little compliance um
oversight that the building control have
but i'd like some reassurance as to
um
you know what what sort of compliance
the local authority can
confer upon um any any development
actually that that comes forward um you
know because we're hearing of the parish
council being misled the ward member
who's got the boots on the ground is
telling us that
the the development seemingly has
morphed into into what it is and the
report mentions you know bits of earth
moving around um and just the simplest
of searches shows not relevant to the
planning application but the simplest
searches shows that um
this is the you know all bar the same
developer that um that baba has had
difficulties with um in the past now not
material to this committee's
considerations however we are elected
members uh and we have primary
responsibility to our constituents so
the question is what level of
supervision can be um can be applied to
any development please
sorry council was that in reference to
supervision in reference to
to the construction phase
building rights
we don't as a matter of ropes you
probably know uh
go and check the sites being built
properly um
obviously there was a recent case with
levels
um which you'll be aware of and we are
aware of that as an issue
um
the issue of the soil
which has been moved on to the site
which could obviously inform part of
your concern has been reported to us um
and i think my colleague will confirm
what we're doing about that
it was raised at outline stage
that this particular developer has
had problems with baber before
about levels
um so we
at outline stage we did put on a
condition for levels to be agreed
prior to commencement
alongside this application for reserve
matters we also have one running for the
discharge of conditions
and one of the conditions to be
discharged is levels
they have been to our enforcement team
for checking over
and they are fine
however because of um
objections or concerns raised during
this application about soil being moved
around
some of the telephone calls i've had are
informal and they haven't been put into
writing
our enforcement team are aware of this
site and i have been assured that they
will be carrying out three monthly
inspections of the site
to make sure
that the levels don't change
dramatically so that the bungalows then
become you know the same level as a
two-story house for example
um and that will be an ongoing process
something put into the diary
and i'm sure while so they're looking at
levels they'll be looking at other
concerns that the parish council may
have as well
any other
comments anybody else wish to make
council jameson
uh thank you looking at the um
the original plan that we agreed
um
the outline plan and this current one i
can understand and tend to agree with
councillor
arthur and the parish that the original
plan was
a lot more open there seemed to be a lot
more free space there for residents and
well this new plan
um
looks a lot more
roady a lot more
look at these a lot more
concentrated on the drop the road and
less on the open space
and um when you compare them side by
side there's a big difference so i can
certainly
understand the
the um unhappiness of the parish council
with this new layout
thank you councilman johnson
anyone else wish to make any comments
concern
thank you mr chairman um
yeah i'm between a rock and a hard place
at the moment but
uh what uh if this application is
approved
obviously i would like to see that
condition for the uh swale and the uh
protection of
small children around it as we've had on
numerous occasions on other applications
so that is certainly one that needs to
be added to the list and i'm not
i'm not
really
trying to put another condition on which
is
effectively hard to maintain sometimes
so
if that is that i'd just like to
say thank you to our officer sam
it was an excellent presentation and i
think um
i think most of the members will agree
that she covered
well all of the situations and answered
all the situations well so thank you sam
thank you
thank you mr chair thank you
can i just ask the question about the
condition
we can add it if we wish
yes we can add uh details to be agreed
for the uh fencing of the suds area and
life belts
but we have to get the proposed in the
second
to agree to that thing
sorry man
mr chairman i'm more than happy it's a
safety issue and i think the agent also
made a point that there was could be
safety concerns
um and
so i would be happy to include that um
you can ask my second in a moment but
could we also add on that um because the
asian did say that he was sympathetic
towards making sure that um they could
control no cars being parked on there
as much as possible so i think that's an
important thing he's shaking his head so
i i think that you could work with him
to make sure that that is also addressed
i i think the agent did actually confirm
that on the revised landscape drawings
there are bullards actually around that
but as as we explained at the time mr
chairman uh they some of the bullets may
be unsightly so there may be other ways
where they can put low hedge in in this
sort of any and that's really all i'm
saying but i'll leave it in your
control and i'm sure that they can you
can work together and i'm happy to
accept the additional condition you're a
second happy to accept the additional
position yeah that sounds very sensible
thank you
chair sorry i didn't catch the second
condition from sam he said boundary
treatment for the swale and there's the
second condition you mentioned
any other
comments
anyone wants to say anything
no if not
we have
a proposal and a secular
can i just ask claire to clarify exactly
what we're voting
on check that the three conditions um i
have other than those already
in writing from the officer are boundary
condition for the swale
provision of life belts for the swale
suds area
and the third one which councilor beer
asked for was for there to be um
boundary treatment to the parking areas
to stop the cars parking on the grass
let's counter it
so i tried to get in um so quick a quick
question if i may the
proposed housing mix of the market
housing
is that similar to
what was proposed in the outline
so in the outline i believe um the some
of the bungalows or one of the bungalows
was uh to be two-bedroomed however the
overall mix of the housing so two three
and four bedroom and the number of those
properties are the same as the outline
even though some of them have changed
between the single story and the
two-story dwellings
anything else
if not i'll hand over to claire
thank you chair members of that vote is
now in progress
council of beer thank you
i need to slow down
thank you chair that's nine votes four
and two against that's carried
thank you very much
that's
thank you all for your attendance um and
the next meeting the planning committee
will be on the 17th of november i now
formally close the meeting
as soon as i've done that
councilors is asked to remind you
you